Well, good morning church.
It is great to gather together like this every week.
Uh, my name's John. I'm one of the pastors here.
I get to preach most of the time.
If I haven't met you yet, I'd love
to meet you sometime soon.
So just come say hi. When you see me.
Today's a really special day.
We are kicking off a new sermon series,
and we're gonna walk through the book
of Second Samuel over the next couple months.
Last fall and spring, we walked
through the book of First Samuel.
And so that began the story.
Now we're going to kind of continue the story
through the book of Second Samuel.
Last week, Aaron, well reminded us that really the whole
story has been about God's people
abandoning God as their king.
Uh, that's really the whole genesis of the story, is
that they were searching instead of following God,
they were searching for an earthly king,
and that has not gone well for them.
And so they did that.
That was really the premise of it was who shall reign?
It really should be God.
But the, the secondary question with that was then, well,
okay, if they're searching for an earthly king,
who's gonna be that king?
And then it was the process of figuring out
who God had promised this type of man to lead the country,
but they had to figure out who that was.
And so we showed this chart, maybe some
of you remember this throughout the whole of First Samuel,
and we tracked how that played out.
And so we saw the transition from judges to kings,
and then how the development happened
where the first king was Saul.
And he looked the part head
and shoulders above every handsome, right?
He's the guy. And he, he seemed like he would be the one,
but his heart was not close to God.
And so God had promised a man
after God's own heart to lead his people.
And that transition from Saul then to David, God,
anointed David to replace Saul.
Well, second Samuel, that was first Samuel.
Second Samuel is David's rise to the throne.
How he steps into that role, and then how he handles it
after he steps into that role.
We're gonna use another chart for second Samuel.
So you might take a picture of this now.
We'll have it up every week at some point, usually.
So, uh, you'll see this a couple times,
but it's gonna be the rise and fall of David.
Now, the idea is yes, we're gonna learn
that David was God's promised king for Israel.
He was the one. But
we'll also see that David was limited.
He was the promised king.
But limited in that role,
there's gonna be a rise to the throne.
Yes, there will be, uh, David's, uh, process
of becoming the greatest King Israel ever had.
But then there's also gonna be faults of David along the way
and the consequences that come from those faults.
See, David is not always the hero
that we make him out to be.
In fact, there's some pretty serious issues,
which really may.
It means something that we need
to set up right here at the beginning of the whole series.
This is something we won't forget, can't forget, is
that David is merely a pointer
to the true promise king.
He's the promise king that, that Israel needed.
But, but he's really just pointing us forward to the true
promised King whose name is Jesus.
That's really what the whole book is about.
So in one sense, we'll see second Samuel's,
like David's testimony, his successes, his failures,
his experiences of God's grace.
That's a great picture for us to learn from.
But it's also the main point how all of that
points us to the Lord.
And so don't forget that as we go through it.
That's why I want to begin just by praying
for this whole series that we're gonna set a tone for this.
We're gonna ask the Lord to bless it, give his his power
as we walk through this power, this passage of scripture.
So, Lord, thank you for the opportunity to study
through your word.
And and we don't, we don't know.
We don't think this is merely man's words.
This is your word. And we know that with that
Holy Spirit, you empower your word.
You highlight, you exalt your word.
And so God, as as we study it over the next couple months,
this unique book of Second Samuel Lord, use it to teach us,
use it to change our hearts and,
and move us forward to be more like you.
As we look to the true promised King that we celebrate
and worship every week, help us God.
It's gotta be your work. It's not mine.
Get us outta the way. Remove distractions that we can see
what you want us to see in Jesus' name.
Amen. And so I invite you now to turn in your copy
of God's word to Second Samuel early in the Old Testament.
You just start from the beginning.
You start flipping back a little bit.
You'll find second Samuel, uh, put a bookmark there
or your, your little ribbon in your Bible
because we'll be there every week as we walk
through this narrative, as you turn there.
It might seem like as we walk through this,
that we're taking really big chunks of scripture.
And and that's partly true because we'll take it two
or three chapters at a time sometimes.
And, and that can seem overwhelming.
But the reality is that's just narrative.
That's just the, the nature of this. You, you have a story.
You can't break it up into little sections
or you lose the point of the story.
So we have to take bigger sections to understand the point
that God was trying to reveal here.
So for example, today we're gonna look at chapters one
through three, three chapters of two Samuel
because part of it recaps
what we already saw at the end of one Samuel.
And the rest of it sets up David to be the king
that we need.
It sets up David, not just as the king,
but also the kind of king that God wanted
for his people.
Not a king who would seize power by violence
or manipulation, but one whose integrity would
shine really brightly.
That's what he was saying through these couple chapters.
God, this God's saying to us, this is the kind of man
that I want to be the king.
And we'll see that in David in these chapters.
How he responds to Saul's death. That's a big test for him.
But also the division we see among God's people.
There's a big test there.
And again, all of it will point us forward
to the true king Jesus.
And so let's look now Second Samuel chapter one.
Again, I can't read all three chapters,
we just don't have enough time for that.
But I'm gonna give you highlights, summary statements,
dive into critical pieces of it and,
and walk through the story so we're not missing anything.
And so what wrap, what happens right outta the gate here
and is, is the parallel account of Saul's death.
The King of Israel has died.
One Samuel 31 was, was the actual story
of Saul dying in the battle scene.
Here. It's David's account.
And, and David's experience at the same parallel time.
'cause what was happening, a big battle
with the Philistines.
These people are trying to overtake Israel.
David's in a different part of the country.
And Saul and his son, Jonathan, who was David's best friend,
by the way, they were in the battle
and they ended up dying in the battle.
Well, here's what happens. One
of the servants from Saul's camp who was an amalekite,
which is one of the defeated enemies of God's people,
he comes to David
and says, Hey David, listen, I'm, I'm telling you some news
you need to know Saul's died.
'cause David didn't know there wasn't Snapchat
or Twitter or anything like that.
It was just like David needed to find out.
Some guy shows up and says, Hey, Saul is dead.
Now here's the thing about this guy.
He wanted to impress David.
He was certain in his mind that David would love
to hear the fact that Saul, his, his enemy, had died.
And so this man walks in, says, Hey David,
listen, Saul's dead.
I got him. I killed him.
Now that's different than what we read in one Samuel 31.
It's a dis, it's distinct from that
because what we read in that is that Saul was
so badly wounded that he had fell on his own sword
and died in the battle.
And so this man walks in this am Malachi
and says, Hey, I killed him.
He's lying in order to curry favor
with the new king.
Maybe he'll give me a a position in his new
kingdom or something like that.
We don't know. But he's clearly lying to impress the king.
Well watch how David responded to the news.
This man came and said, Hey, I got Saul. He's dead.
I did it. Aren't you proud?
Watch David's response verses 11 and 12 here in chapter one.
Then David took hold of his clothes and tore them.
That's a sign of grief.
And so did all the men who were with him and they mourned
and wept and fasted until evening for Saul
and for Jonathan, his son, and for the people of the Lord
and for the house of Israel
because they had fallen by the sword.
Now, don't forget who Saul was.
Saul was the man who had multiple times tried to kill David.
He'd hunted him like a wild animal.
He had kept him on the run for 10 years. This was the man.
Saul was the man that we see.
David's heart show up.
Saul was the man that David was
grieving for his loss.
Instead of hatred, there was grief.
Instead of rejoicing over his enemy's death,
there was mourning.
David grieved the loss of God's anointed king that Saul was.
He even wrote a song of lament.
David wrote most of the Psalms, you can go through
and find his name on a lot of those.
He wrote a song of lament to be sung
by God's people over the loss of Saul
and Jonathan, we find it here in chapter one,
verses 19 through 27.
You can read the whole thing. I'm just gonna read a
couple pieces to show you.
It says verse 19, your glory,
Israel is slain on your high places.
How the mighty have fallen.
Verse 23, Saul and Jonathan, beloved
and lovely in life and death.
They were not divided. They were swifter than eagles,
stronger than lions.
He's upholding them. Verse 27, how the mighty have fallen
and the weapons of war perished.
So he wrote a song, uh, of grief for the nation to sing.
Not only that, watch how he responded to the amalekite man
who came and told him about Saul's death.
Look at verses 14 through 16.
David said to him, how is it you were not afraid
to put out your hand to destroy the Lord's anointed?
Then David called one of the young men
and said, go execute him.
And he struck him down so that he died.
And David said to the amalekite, man,
your blood be on your head
for your own mouth has testified against you saying,
I have killed the Lord's anointed.
He had the man who claimed to have killed Saul.
He had him executed right like
This man, this Amalekite man should have recognized the
sanctity of God's anointed king.
He should have been terrified to touch him
because remember that's what David did when David was
fleeing from Saul had multiple chances
to take Saul out instead of Saul trying to kill him.
He didn't. He said, no, no,
I'm not gonna touch the Lord's anointed.
He repeated that multiple times.
I'm not touching the Lord's anointed.
I'm not going to gain the throne improperly.
God promised it to me. I'm not gonna do it myself.
I'm going to allow God to do it.
This Amalekite man said a whole different mindset.
He's like, I'm gonna manipulate this whole situation
to my ends.
And what happened? He paid the ultimate price.
So here's the point. David revealed his heart in his
response to Saul's death.
That's what we see here.
David revealed his passionate love for God,
a man after God's own heart.
David revealed that here by the way.
He responded to his enemy,
Saul dying 'cause he
Think about it. He could have rejoiced that. Saul's gone.
My opponent is gone. The pathway to the throne is clear.
Now I got this. I'm king. Now it's clear.
But he doesn't do that.
Which leads us to a question for us today.
Is that how you love your enemies?
Like do you grieve when your enemy suffers?
If your opponent or the antagonist in your life dies?
Do you mourn for their death?
Or are you more apt
to throw a party like, man, they deserve it.
They got what they deserve. Finally,
and listen, we saw this as we studied Romans 12 this summer,
one of the most challenging realignment statements in
Romans 12 verses 19 and 20.
Beloved never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God.
For it is written, vengeance is mine,
I will repay, says the Lord.
To the contrary, if your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, giving something to drink for, by so doing,
you will heap burning coals on his head.
It doesn't say if he's hungry, laugh at him.
If he's thirsty, keep pushing him further away.
No, it says you provide,
you love them Again.
Remember, David had multiple opportunities
to take out his enemy to kill Saul, but he didn't do it
'cause he trusted that God's justice is perfect.
Our revenge is never perfect.
We don't know the situation fully.
We will not do it rightly
and we'll be guilty on the other side of it.
So David trusted God to deal with the situation.
And you know what? It ended up actually way better
for David than if he had taken Saul out
some other way, some other time.
It ended up better for David
'cause no one could accuse David of anything.
At this point. He's in a
whole different part of the country.
He had no knowledge of it even happening.
And now David is the king.
His hands were clean. Why?
Because of Romans 12, that mentality.
He said, I'm gonna overcome evil with good.
I'm not gonna, like Martin Luther King Jr.
Said, I'm not gonna overcome evil with evil
'cause that just multiplies evil.
I'm gonna overcome evil with good.
And we see the result. And
so let's just play this out for us.
If, if that attitude is true of us, if that's commanded
of us,
Don't you think that should mean our lives look pretty
different Than the way of the world, even than
what they commonly do.
It means things should be very different in
how we speak about those who oppose us, those
who are considered enemies, those are antagonizing us.
We should speak differently about them.
Our social media usage should be very different in the way
we speak about people.
That way our bumper stickers on our car should not be just
like everybody else's in the world.
If this is the mentality, if Jesus said to love your enemies
and to pray for those who persecute you, we should refuse
to rejoice when someone on the other side
of the aisle suffers.
We should be radically different in the way we treat
those who oppose us.
Now, I'm not saying we trust those people,
but I am saying we ought to speak as well as we can of them.
Even if they've hurt us, we should try to honor
what we can in that image bearer of God like we are.
And yes, we don't give everything away to them,
but despite their failures toward us,
if Jesus looked at his enemies
and said, father, forgive them, we can do the same.
That's what David models so well.
His heart was so in love with God
that he could love his enemy, by grieving his enemy's death,
by honoring him through a song.
This man who persecuted him.
I mean, that's the kind of king that God wanted, right?
It's a good king. So
that's one aspect of his qualifications.
Here's another In this chapters two
and three, we start to see
some things show up in David again that adds
to the qualifications again.
When Saul died, it seemed like now there's a clear path
to the throne like David, man, it's yours now.
Everything is good except for like the uh,
legend once said, not so fast my friend.
We're gonna throw the chart back up there
and you'll see it on the left.
David was immediately anointed king of Judah,
which was only one of the 12 tribes of Israel.
And then you see that he moved to Hebron,
which is a small town in the south.
It's not Jerusalem, which is eventually going to be the,
the the capital that we will find out, of course.
But he's in Hebron. He's down in the middle of nowhere.
King of just one of the 12 tribes.
Because here's what happened.
Abner, who is the commander of Saul's army,
Abner, took one of Saul's other sons
who didn't die in the battle.
His name was ish Boche,
which is not on the top 10 baby names.
I don't know why, but ish Boche,
He took that son and said, you're the king.
Your dad was Saul, you're the king of these tribes.
All of Israel. 11.
Well, David's over here, king of one tribe, Judah,
which is really small too.
And him and Joab, his military commander,
they're over here doing this and Israel chef
and Abner over here doing this.
It, it starts to smell like civil war, doesn't it?
And, and things are starting to heat up a little bit here
that, that Abner didn't like David.
And so he's like, I'm gonna make Raeth the king
and this is what's gonna look now.
Well it was clearly a case of human, human intuition.
Human wisdom versus divine appointment.
David anointed by God as the king
Abner says, no, no, no.
Eth gonna be the king. Well watch what happens.
Look at chapter three.
Skip ahead a little bit to chapter three verse one.
We're gonna see the results of that as we go.
We're skipping a lot of the battles that happened.
But watch this verse one of chapter three.
There was a long war between the house
of Saul and the house of David.
And David grew stronger
and stronger while the house of Saul became weaker
and weaker Even
through a battle, God was fulfilling his promise to David
to shift the kingdom to David.
It was happening. God was bringing about the fulfillment
of his promise.
But here's what's interesting about how this played out.
What happened next is that Abner who was with the 11 tribes
and with the king, he anointed, he actually defects
and changes his mind
because of something the is Israel did to him.
He changed his mind and said, no,
I'm following David now he defects
and comes over to follow David
and all the 11 tribes begin to trickle alongside with him.
We'll see that over the next couple chapters.
But there was a problem. Abner was the enemy
military commander, David's commander Joe AB was not
involved in those conversations.
Joe AB has no idea this is happening.
He's out doing the work
and he comes home, watch what he thought was happening.
This is verses 22 through 25
of chapter three Starting verse 22.
Just then the service of David arrived
with Joab from a raid, bringing much spoil with them.
But Abner was not with David at Hebron. He'd sent him away.
He'd gone in peace when Job
and all the army with him came, it was told Joab, Abner, son
of Ner came to the king.
He's let him go, he's gone in peace.
And then Joab went to the king and said, what have you done?
The old Abner came to you.
Why is it that you sent him away so that he's gone?
You know, Abner, the son of Ner came to deceive you
and to know you're going out.
You're coming in and to know all that you are doing.
Now here's a little side note, why would Abner not?
Well Joe Ab not trust Abner, partly
'cause he was on the other side, but also
Abner had killed Joe Abs brother in a battle earlier.
So there was already personal
animosity between the two of them.
And Job's like, dude, listen, he David, he's coming to try
to figure out our plans.
He's deceiving. You don't trust him.
Well watch how Joab handled this situation verses 26
and 27, when Joab came out from God's,
from David's presence, he sent messengers after Abner
and they brought him back from the cistern of Sarah.
But David did not know about this.
And When Abner returned to he
and Joab took him aside in the midst of the gate
to speak with him privately.
And there he struck him in the stomach so that he died
for the blood of Asel, his brother.
This is a test for David, isn't it?
You've got division among the people, you've got conflict
among his leaders.
It's a test of David as the new king.
Plus you have not only the divisions, you have this murder.
Now that it could have come back on David,
that he manipulated the enemy's death.
He brought Abner in here, he deceived him
and then sent Joe AB to go finish the job.
Like no, he, he could have been read that way.
If it's not that at,
at the very least it's you got a general murdering another
general, like that's not so it's a problem.
It's a test. How was David gonna lead through the crisis?
Watch verse 28.
Afterward when David heard of it, he said,
I in my kingdom are forever guiltless
before the Lord for the blood of Abner, the son of Ner.
Like he publicly disavowed anything, any involvement.
He didn't have anything to do with this.
Even the next verse, he calls down a curse on Joab
because Joab took vengeance he shouldn't have.
David says, I didn't do it, Joab did it and he was wrong.
Now verses 31 and 32, watch.
And then David said to Joab
and to all the people who were with him, tear your clothes
and put on sackcloth and mourn before Abner
and King David followed the beer.
That's the the coffin.
They buried Abner at Hebron and the king lifted up his voice
and wept at the grave of Abner and all the people wept.
This sounds familiar, doesn't it?
It's what he did with Saul enemy number one. Saul.
David grieved him.
Abner was on the other side with Saul
and he grieved abner's loss publicly.
And now verse 35.
And then all the people came to persuade David
to eat bread while it was yet day.
But David swore saying, God do so to me
and more also if I taste bread
or anything else till the sun goes down.
That's just signs of grief.
He's lamenting fasting publicly saying You should be
grieving the loss of Abner too.
So he's again, showing his heart.
But watch what all that did.
Here's why I went through this watch
what happens next verses 36 and 37,
and all the people took notice of it
and it pleased them as everything
that the king did, pleased all the people.
So all the people of and all Israel understood that day.
It had not been the king's will to put to death.
Abner, the son of Ner.
Like you see what happened, David, in his transparent
integrity filled leadership,
he won the hearts of the people.
Like, no, no, David didn't do that. That was Joab.
We love David. We trust David. Watch how he's responded.
It won the people's hearts.
You see why God could trust David
with the kingship of his people.
His heart was close to God, he was wanting
to do all the right things in every situation.
David led through division, he led
with integrity like that.
That's the point here. Even through division, the chaos
murders and, and people divided and,
and tribes splitting up like all of this.
David was like, I, I have integrity
and I'm going to lead with it through all of that.
Now, what is integrity? Basic
answer, integrity is when your private life matches
your public testimony, the way you think and live
and act inside yourself matches the way
that you act publicly.
You're the same in every situation. Is that true of you?
And and I'm not just saying like when things are really
good, you know you can do
that when things are good in your life,
of course you can act the same way with everybody.
It's not, that's not a problem.
But when things fall apart, crumble, it begins
to really squeeze out what's
actually in the sponge of your heart.
Are you the same in every situation? That's integrity.
And I man, this, this was hard, this part was hard
for me this week to write,
but let's just think about how we as Christians
don't do this very well.
Think about how often what we say
we believe and how we should live
doesn't in any way match the way we actually live.
And I don't just say that to, to say, well,
I think objectively kind of, you know, it's,
it's a bit of here and there.
I see it happen from time to time.
No, statistically this bears out that we
as Christians say, we believe and do certain things
but we actually don't.
Let give you a couple examples.
We talk about sexual purity a lot.
Yet pornography
and just messing around runs rampant,
not just in younger people, in every generation
we declare the the sacredness.
Now we as Christians, marriage is sacred
and yet hundreds upon hundreds of spouses are abused
and mistreated and are terrified to go home Within churches.
We, we say we believe in caring for the poor, caring
for the outcast in providing generously to people in need.
Yet our money and our time flow to the lakehouse
or to more toys for ourselves.
We say we believe, we say we treasure and cherish,
and yet our lives look so far from it.
And we could go on and on. There's list after list.
But listen, when our lives don't come close to matching
what we say, the world looks at this
and just sees it as religious performance.
They don't see true faith.
What they see is a social club with a little bit
of morality sprinkled on top of it.
And so something needs to change in our lives, right?
Like is that all this is?
Is this just a social club
that we have some Jesus language on top?
Is that all? Is that all this is something needs
to change in our lives?
How do we get to that level of integrity
where we're the same person every situation, every situation
of life, we're gonna look the same externally, internally,
regardless of how our life's going.
How can we get there? How did David get there?
Go back quickly to chapter two verse one.
Just quickly look at this Chapter two verse one.
This was right after Saul died,
the crisis moment of his life.
He could decide to go whichever way he wanted.
Watch this verse one
after this, David inquired of the Lord,
shall I go up into the any of the cities of Judah?
The Lord said to him, go up.
Okay, David said, all right, to which shall I go up?
And he said to Hebrew, did you see what that phrase was?
David inquired of the Lord.
That phrase appears at least six times in first
and second Samuel, Like as he is deciding where
to go, deciding what to do.
Should I do this? Should I, how could I talk this way?
David inquired to the Lord, David inquire to the Lord.
That's revealing something about his heart, right?
It means David's highest priority was knowing God's will
and obeying God's will.
David, I God's, God's saying, David is saying,
God, I want to follow you.
I wanna know your will. I wanna be obedient to you.
He, he had integrity
and he was saying, God, I trust your will over my ambition.
I want nothing else but your will.
Any authority he received came from his
submission to the ultimate authority.
It wasn't him claiming it, it was him receiving it
and he lived it out with integrity.
Is that how you live your life?
Have you said to your heavenly father, not my will,
but your will be done in every
situation, every moment.
Your highest priority is God, I wanna obey you.
Your commands, your leadership,
everything in my life is all yours.
Or are you more focused on your personal ambition,
your personal preferences, your way of doing things?
Are you trying to force through your plan instead of waiting
for God's timing?
Are you going about your life?
And man, this is really easy for me to do.
Are you going through your life saying, okay,
I've got all this intuition, I've got all this knowledge,
I've got all this history.
I know how to live my life. I know where I'm going.
I don't need you. God, none of us would ever say
that, but we live it.
Instead of humbly coming to prayerfully, coming
to God's Word and saying, God, what do you want?
Like God, what's your will?
Clearly commands are his will.
But then he's like he,
he's not maybe gonna write it on the sky where you should go
to college or where you should do this
or that, or who are you gonna marry?
Whatever it is like he, but,
but you should filter it through the lens.
God, show me God.
Tell me whichever way
and trust he's gonna lead your pathway as you go.
Is that the way you live your life?
Every moment you wake up of the day and
and every moment of the day you say, God, not my will,
but your will be done on Friday night.
When that temptation comes, God,
not my will, your will be done.
When you face that crisis moment in your family, God,
not my will, your will be done at work
and you're tempted to do a little bit of cutting corners,
God, not my will, but your will be done.
Is that how you live your life?
That's the environment integrity grows in.
That's when you submit to the the will of the Father
and you say, God, I'm getting out of the way.
It's yours. I'm following you.
He makes you more Christ-like
'cause you obey Him, you follow him.
And that's how he grows the character in you
that looks more like Jesus in the small things
as he prepares you for something that may be bigger later
and so far in first and second Samuel.
But we've seen David do that pretty well.
But sadly that won't last very long.
You may remember the story in Genesis of the Garden of Eden
and Adam and Eve, like it was really good for two chapters.
And then chapter three, it all tanks
and everything goes south.
And, and we'll see David
fall into some of the same traps that Saul
and others did as the king,
which again leads us to the overall point of these books.
Yes, David's a great example.
He's a man after God's own heart.
He's Israel's greatest king.
But hear me, David is not the hero of this story.
He's merely a pointer to the true hero.
The one who fulfilled all that David could merely
resemble Jesus Christ.
Jesus fulfilled
what David could only bear some resemblance to
Now we're gonna see David.
Yes, he appeared to be a savior in many ways.
He re, he brought the nation together.
He was a savior of his people.
He was kind of Messiah like kind of Christ-like in a way.
He was a type. He taught us a lot about the Messiah to come,
but he is not the savior.
There's a true greater king to come after David,
and he's the one that we stand today
and we worship the perfect king who did everything in full
that David could only do in part who fulfilled it all.
Everything David did imperfectly.
Jesus did perfectly just listen to how he did this,
how Jesus is the greater David.
He loved his enemies, not just by grieving for them,
but by dying for them.
Jesus sought the Father's will perfectly, even in the garden
of Gethsemane when he's facing the, the horror of the cross,
the very next day he said,
not my will, but your will be done.
He always led with complete transparency and integrity.
Hebrews four 15, we do not have a high priest who's unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses,
but one who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
That's our king. Perfect.
And because of that perfection,
because of that obedience through his death
and resurrection, he has ended the ultimate division
between God
and humanity, by bringing sinners back home
to God the Father, the civil war
that David faced has no candle to hold
to the desperate dependence we have on God
to take sinners home with him only through his work.
That is our king. That's who this is pointing us to.
And all praise should go to that true king Jesus Christ.
Let's pray. God, thank you so much for your grace
and mercy, your word pointing us to those truths.
And I pray, God, that, that we would recognize
and see you as the true king.
Learn from what we can with David,
but point to you, look to you, worship you.
But I know there's some of us walked in this room today,
and we've spent most of our lives looking for a king
in this world, somebody to satisfy, somebody
to fulfill somebody, to protect
something, to do all of that.
And they are disappointed and exhausted in that search.
Some have walked in here looking for themself
to be the king, to be able to live it out perfectly,
to be this one that that I just described.
And they're recognizing that they can't do that.
They never could. And so God,
what you're just showing us always is that we need
to savior king and praise
the Father that you provided.
God the Son, took on flesh to do all of this
so that we could be saved, which means you're worthy.
So God, draw us to yourself in that.
Help us see you rightly
and respond to you rightly, in Jesus' name.
Amen. Part of that response today involves the Lord's.